vous
je déteste voler les lignes les foules les
retards que je collectionne toujours six heures un
siège n'a pas eu - mesdames et
messieurs bienvenue à bord de notre service sans escale
de New York à Londres coule
beaucoup tout le temps en fait
quelqu'un sur ce vol menace de
tuer  quelqu'un toutes les 20 minutes
eh bien, 150 millions de dollars sont
transférés sur ce numéro de compte, nous sommes à
mi-chemin de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique, comment
tuer quelqu'un dans un avion bondé et s'en
tirer
mesdames et messieurs, il faut que chaque
passager lève les mains au-dessus de
sa tête  est une mauvaise idée
maréchal nous avons le droit de savoir ce que
diable l'agent marque le numéro de compte que vous
nous avez donné est à votre nom ce qui
n'a aucun sens c'est une configuration
quelque chose d'autre se passe sur
le FBI la Maison Blanche et Interpol
confirment des informations selon lesquelles un
vol international a été détourné par un
maréchal de l'air est à bord notre escorte de chasse
vous a dans son viseur ne m'entendez-vous pas
nous manquons de temps m'entendez-vous
pouvez  ne pas attaquer est un plan,
j'essaie de te le sauver